- I had actually kind
of had grown jaded
with the television business
and local news business
because there had been a lot
of corporate consolidation.
And there was less
autonomy at the local level
for reporters like myself
and anchors to
pursue stories that
I felt like were really
important to our audience.
There were a lot of mandates
from the corporate offices
and edicts from on high,
and we're gonna focus on this
and I think that's problematic
with our country right now
where you have a
lot less local news,
a lot less investment
in local news
and you have less
coverage of the places
where the rubber really meets
the road in our democracy,
and that's in your County
Commission meetings,
your school board meetings,
your city council meetings.
(intense ambient music)
- I'm Dave Rubin
and joining me today is the
host of John Bachman Now,
on Newsmax, John Bachman
welcome to the Rubin Report.
- Dave, great to be with you.
- I felt that I had to do that
a little more as a news anchor
(laughing)
because
I'm with a news anchor,
did that seem right to you?
- Well, I appreciate
it, because you know,
when I have you on my show
I always try to do the reverse
(laughing)
and try to be more Dave
Rubinesk, more free flowing.
You know, maybe I should
just unbutton the top collar
fair bit, right?
- You know what,
unbutton the tie for God sake.
- Let's loosen it
a little bit.
We're on YouTube, right?
- Yeah.
- Maybe I'll unbutton the jacket
and we can relax a
little bit, right,
let's do it.
- Yeah.
- Let's settle in
- Calm down, if you wanna
unfurl the hair a little bit,
whatever you wanna
do, you're okay here.
Listen, I am glad
to have you on,
I feel like you're the
right guy to have on
sorta just a little bit
before inauguration,
we are in a
seriously weird time.
And as I often tell my audience,
I just have this
short list of people
that are even remotely
sane right now
and I kind of put you
on that list.
- Oh, well.
- For the people that
have no idea who you are,
just give me a little bit
of the John Bachman story
and then we'll talk about
the news of the day.
- Well, I imagine that's
most of your audience,
I'm kinda new to
this internet thing,
I'm a traditional
TV news anchor type,
I worked for about 20
years in local news,
started as an intern at
WAGA Fox Five in Atlanta
and then went to Augusta,
Georgia the CBS affiliate there,
WADA, and then moved down
to West Palm beach, Florida
because I wanted to be kind of
on the political fault
lines of American politics
and of course, West Palm beach,
Palm beach County was
one of those areas
where you have a pretty
diverse political population
and it turned out to be
everything I expected and more,
you know, I come to Newsmax
from that perspective,
I had actually kind
of had grown jaded
with the television business
and local news business,
because there had been a lot
of corporate consolidation
and there was less
autonomy at the local level
for reporters like myself
and anchors to
pursue stories that
I felt like were really
important to our audience.
There were a lot of mandates
from the corporate offices
and you know edicts
from on high,
and we're gonna focus on this
and
(sighs)
I think that's problematic
with our country right now
where you have a
lot less local news,
a lot less investment
in local news,
and you have less
coverage of the places
where the rubber really meets
the road in our democracy.
And that's in your County
Commission meetings
your school board meetings,
your city council meetings
and we're seeing this
right now I think Dave
with the vaccine rollout or
you had a very successful
operation Warp Speed
on the federal level,
and then when those resources,
whether it's vaccines
or money from FEMA,
when they get down
on the local level,
you really see a breakdown
and the ability to execute
these types of national plans.
And here I am, you
know I worked so hard,
this was always kind of my goal
to get to a place where I
had a national audience,
but now that we're
here and you see the,
you know the pandemic response
and the disparate response
from California and New York
versus Florida and
how it's affecting
the mental health of people,
and, you think about other
things too, in Georgia
or other states where you
had a complete breakdown
of confidence in
the election system,
you realize that this is really
where our focus needs to be now
and so as we kind of
reposition ourselves here,
looking ahead to the
Biden administration,
and of course keeping
an eye on that,
we have got to also
do a better job
of introducing America
to state houses
and what's going
on at a local level
so that we can understand
what's not working
in this country.
I mean, this is still a
federalist system we have
and we're all fighting
to protect that,
and we still have, fortunately,
we still have this kind of
laboratory of ideas when it
comes to different policies
and prescriptions for problems
we have in this country.
And again, we're seeing that
with this with this pandemic
and completely different
approaches from Cuomo
and Gavin Newsome
versus Ron DeSantis
and we know sometimes
that doesn't work
and now, I'm sure
a lot of people
are looking at the Florida model
and say, maybe Florida
man isn't so crazy.
So that's kind of a
winding narrative here
but you know why I'm
attracted to you Dave
and why I had you on our show
is because this
idea of free thought
and that's why I'm
here at Newsmax now
because this provides
me the platform
to do the things I couldn't do
as a traditional quote
unquote news anchor.
- It's interesting,
I asked you John Bachman 101
a little bit about your history,
we talked about COVID
response, federalism,
government, television,
the whole thing,
so before we go any further,
you work for Newsmax.
- Yes.
- Isn't that some
sort of far right
crazy extremist network,
John?
- That's what they tell me.
You know,
the funny thing is too Dave
(chuckles)
is it's all that, of course
in some people's minds,
then at the same
time, I'm a traitor,
for saying all the
way back in December
and just trying to tell the
audience that yes, you know
the bar is very high for Joe
Biden not to become president.
I think we talked about
this that at a certain point
it was like a space shuttle
that had launched into the sky,
and if it didn't make
it into space into orbit
it was gonna be some sort of
catastrophic explosion
that would prevent it,
and it never happened,
I mean, we're here now.
And it, you know, I think,
you know, when you're taking
flack from the extreme right
as we are, when people
call me a traitor
for calling Joe Biden
the president elect
or from the far left, because
we just wanna do
something simple
as carry the president of
the United States speech,
which I think we were the
only major network to do that
this week when the president
was down at the border,
I mean, he's still the
president of the United States
and his words still matter
and nobody really
wants to do that.
What we try to do is kind
of chart a different path
and provide information
that wasn't being provided
for a lot of people
and that somehow Dave has
become a radical idea.
- Do you find it sort of
tough to be a news anchor
in a time when not only is
there cable news obviously
and sort of the
dying dinosaur of
the big three cable
news channels,
but now there's a whole bunch
of other channels like Newsmax,
then there's like
the gazillion people
on YouTube and podcasts
and everywhere else,
but finding a niche that
actually makes sense
that's still true to who you are
is sort of tough just business
wise and everything else.
- Yes, I do, I think it
is tough in some respects.
I mean, I think,
you know there are
very few places
that can provide me
this type of opportunity
there are other great people
we have that work for us.
I mean, you know
Chris Roddy our CEO
really is a believer in
the idea of a big tent
and you know, individuality
and you know the
competition of ideas and
that's what he promotes
and it was kind of kind of a
random way that he and I met,
I talked about my background
as a TV news reporter,
I remember one day
specifically I woke up,
was reading the newspaper,
the Palm Beach Post
and I read it a little blurb,
there was a great
political reporter
who no longer works
in local news.
He's gone on to do other things,
his name is George Bennett.
He wrote about the
fact that Sarah Pailin
was going to a place
called Newsmax to visit,
this was after the 2008
presidential election,
she was obviously
a lightning rod
and I wanted to go
meet Sarah Pailin.
I was fascinated by her story,
her appeal to conservatives.
And so I showed up at Newsmax,
not knowing much about Newsmax
and I worked the parking lot,
met some of the people who
showed up to meet Sarah Pailin
and asked them why they
were interested in her
and they liked her
outsider philosophy.
And you know, at that same time
that's when I met Chris
ruddy, the CEO of Newsmax
and he and I struck
up a conversation,
he and I talked
about a lot of things
I had expressed at that point,
kind of my disillusionment
with the local news business,
and he gave me his business card
and said, hey, let's
go to lunch sometime.
And at that point
I was interested in
what he had to say
about the business
and long story short,
that was 10 years ago
and he had mentioned
at that lunch
the idea of starting
a cable news network
because he felt like there
was a vast portion of America
that even with Fox News
and other conservative outlets
that were not being reached.
And so here we are
all these years later,
to have this opportunity
to be on your show,
to have this new audience
find us as an alternative
and a compliment to the
spectrum of conservative media
that's available is
just really humbling.
- Isn't that actually the
cool part that it's like
there are all these
networks popping up,
you know, right leaning
or conservatively networks
and I don't sense that,
well, although obviously at
some level there's competition,
there's only so many ad dollars
to go around or
whatever it might be,
but it's like, there's the
Blaze there's Daily Wire,
there is Newsmax,
there's more and more,
there's independent guys,
there's the whole thing
and it's like, everyone's
kind of helping everybody.
I go on everybody's shows, I'm
happy to promote everybody,
and it's like, man, we
just need more and more.
If I find a new
voice that's good,
I'm like, man, come with me.
Come with me on this adventure.
- I'm with you a 100% Dave,
and the way I kind
of look at this
and forgive me
'cause I have some Southeastern
conference bias here
you know, congratulations
to Alabama and everything,
I'm a Georgia grad,
but I consider conservative
media almost like the SCC,
like the elite of the media,
(laughing)
and you know, you may be
Alabama and I'm Georgia here
but when it comes, we
might compete in our league
but when the time is right,
when it really matters,
like on election night,
you know we're
gonna be in position
to really have the best ideas
because we compete
with our ideas.
And I think in the long term
you ask people of a certain age,
they're more conservators at
the later end of your lifespan
than the younger folks,
it's because conservative ideas
eventually do win out over time,
when you have the
advantage of perspective
and longevity and
history to look back on,
you realize that the
things that got us here
to where we are as a
country have worked
and most of those things
whether it's federalism
or, you know,
checks and balances,
those kind of old school ideas,
it's really conservatives
that have continued
to talk about those things
and really defend those
principles throughout history.
- And it's very exciting
because we have those things
for another seven days.
(laughing)
- Well, I honestly
think, I mean,
this is scary for a
lot of folks here but
I'm reminded of many
times in history
when we talked about
how bad things could be,
I try to take stock in the fact
that we do have the
most divided Congress
basically we've ever
had in our history,
almost as evenly
split as it could be
in the house and the Senate.
And for somebody
like Kamala Harris
who was the deciding vote,
the tie breaker in the Senate,
she has an enormous
amount of responsibility,
and I think, and I hope
that she will weigh
that responsibility
because it's gonna
be on her shoulders.
You know, they're talking
about eliminating
electoral college now,
that's their big thing.
(chuckles)
And does she really want
that on their record?
You know, eliminating
all the history
and all the positive
things that that has done
to thwart the tyranny
of the masses,
the things that could have,
if it weren't for the
electoral college,
slavery would have existed
probably much longer Dave.
So these are the things
they wanna tear down,
we know it's kind of
symbolic at this point
and I'm really hopeful while
at the same time skeptical
that they actually
want to do this stuff
because they know
based on what happened,
like, you know the Supreme
court, for example,
that there are
unintended consequences
and it usually comes back
to bite them in the ass.
- Yeah.
Listen, I hope you're right,
I do hope you're right,
but I actually
think they wanna do
absolutely everything that
they say they wanna do
and the electoral college stuff,
the PAC and the court stuff,
whether it's post
impeachment of Trump,
like just whatever crazy bananas
thing someone puts up there,
I think they wanna do all of it.
I just see, do you see
any reason to think,
is there anything in
the movement right now
that comes up as like
a roadblock for you
that they're like,
oh, well maybe they'll
turn around now,
I mean, they are seeing
the cliff over there.
I mean, maybe this
one, you think?
- Well, I had hoped so,
I had Mark Halperin
on my show today
kind of looking at the public
opinion, polling available
on this impeachment issue
is pretty weak right now
but there are polls out there
that showed us the same thing
as it showed us last time
when they were talking
about impeachment,
the country is evenly
divided on this
and I still believe
in the collective
kind of power of the
individual of course,
but the American public too
and there were a
lot of promises made
about $2,000 stimulus
checks from the Democrats,
especially those who recently
won those seats in Georgia.
If they failed to
deliver on that,
I think there's gonna
be enormous blow back
from this country again
because they're being
disingenuous about
their true motives.
And the American
public is a lot smarter
than I think Nancy Pelosi and
Chuck Schumer and Joe Biden
and Kamala Harris
give them credit for,
and again that's
why I'm optimistic
still at the end of the day
Dave is because we still have
75 million people in this
country who appear sane,
and you know which side
(laughing)
I'm talking about,
which voters.
And again, I don't wanna
pretend like I'm a partisan here
but when you look
at the comparison,
it's a stark contrast and
it's hard for me
to see how people
went the other way sometimes.
But again, that's
just my opinion,
I guess I can say that
here in this forum.
- Well, I'm curious though,
how do you balance that
on a day to day basis?
Like when I do your show,
it's pretty obvious to
me that you're a profe-,
like you are a
professional news man,
do you consider yourself a
traditional journalist still?
- No, I.
- Because you're,
it's obvious to me
(chuckles)
that you have opinions and
you're not afraid to say them
but you are presenting news.
- I think there's almost
an expectation now
from the audience not
to give your opinion
but to be honest about
where you're coming from
and I always talk about,
this is not
necessarily my opinion,
it's more or less
my perspective,
giving people some insight
on where I'm coming from,
you know, I grew up
in the deep South
but my parents are
from the Northeast,
I almost, I consider myself a
first generation Southerner,
even growing up in the
eighties and nineties
Catholic in the Deep South
with Northern parents,
you'd have friends and they'd
be somewhat skeptical of,
are your carpet back,
what's going on here
(laughing)
that type of thing.
But again, you know,
it's a diverse kind
of background to have
and a different way
of thinking at things
and that's kind of just
always shaped my perspectives,
but people expect you to
kind of be honest with them
where you're coming
from on these things.
So I like to, say I
do two things here,
I'm gonna lay out
the facts for you
and then I'm gonna tell you why
specifically we chose
those set of facts
because I have a limited
time for my show,
so there are only so many
facts I can provide in there,
and there are other news outlets
that focus on other facts.
But these are the
facts that I think
are the most important facts
and those facts come based on
my history, where I grew up,
what I believe, the
books I'm reading,
the movies I'm watching
and so I do try to
give the audience
insight on those things
so they have kind of perspective
on where my perspective
is coming from.
And that, I talk
about this with my
college journalism
professor all the time,
David Hasinsky who used
to work at NBC news.
He is admittedly a liberal
and we argue about
politics all the time,
but when it comes to the
practice of journalism,
you know the rules are still
the same at the end of the day,
trust your sources,
give attribution to where
your information comes from,
only choose sources that
are really trustworthy,
tell people the truth,
what has happened,
don't speculate too much
and you stay within those
lines, it's not hard,
I mean, it is hard,
it's difficult,
but you can do both Dave.
Give people the facts,
be honest with them about
what's gonna happen,
don't be afraid to call
him the president elect
when you know it's
gonna upset the audience
because they might be upset
with you for a day or two
and some people might
change the channel,
but come January 20th,
when I was honest with
the audience about what
historically and
constitutionally the limits
were for what actually
were gonna happen
and that, Lynnwood
might not be right.
Long-term when you are right,
they gravitate back towards you
and they respect you for
being honest with them.
And that's, what you're able
to do with your audience,
that is what I hope the
internet still provides,
you're still on YouTube,
thank God for that.
(laughing)
You know,
and I think you're about
to cross 1.5 million
followers on YouTube
and YouTube would be nuts
to take that platform
away from you
because it would, you
would really upset
or pissed-off I can
say, 1.5 million people.
So, just like I have faith
in the overall population
of the country,
I have faith in those
1.5 million people
who follow you on YouTube
and that they would pick up
the phone or do something
to force you to make sure that
you still have this platform.
- Yeah, I hope you're right.
You know, I'm usually the
optimist on these interviews
when I bring on people
who give me like,
uh-oh, the whole world's going
to hell in a hand basket,
but you're giving me the
optimist approach here.
Do you think it's kind of funny
when like CNN, for example,
like none of their anchors,
not that they ever
really do interviews,
but that if they
did an interview,
I don't think that Wolf Blitzer
or Don Lemon or Jake
Tapper or Brian Stelter
or whatever the other made
up names are, pretend humans,
I don't think that
they would admit
the biases that you
just admit there.
I think they would say no,
we're calling balls and strikes,
(chuckles)
and it is what it is.
Even Chris Cuomo, the
biggest clown in cable news,
I think he would say, no,
I'm not a Democrat
or a Republican, I'm
not left or right,
I'm a newsman.
And it's that sort of
fraudulent nonsense
that people can't stand.
- My kind of test
for a news anchor,
I like to ask them how much time
did you spend out in the
street as a reporter?
How many doors did you knock?
How many pairs of shoes
did you ruin stepping
in things you shouldn't step in
because you're a reporter
and maybe you shouldn't
have been there?
You know, I think like
that's kind of what's
missing a lot of times
from our news anchors
is they haven't talked
to enough regular people.
The emphasis in
this business is on
get to the top as
fast as you can,
young and shiny objects,
that type of thing.
But I agree with you,
not that Wolf Blitzer
is one of those guys,
is that they would tell
you with a straight face
that they are
giving you the facts
and maybe that's
what they believe
because they're in that sphere.
But I think the
thing that's really
hurting the media industry today
is that it's hard for
Chris Cuomo to go out
and have a dinner
with his family
and be a normal person
(laughing) or go
to a grocery store
and buy groceries
without being accosted.
You know, and I don't
agree with a lot
of what Chris Cuomo says,
I don't know if you
saw that exchange
with him and Don Lemon,
Don Lemon doesn't
have a law degree
(chuckles)
but Don Lemon schooled him
the other night on free speech,
it was kind of
interesting to see,
but I worry not just about
our celebrity news people
or our celebrity lawmakers,
I worry about people
being able to have
real life
interactions with humans.
- Yeah.
- And really find out
from the guy at the deli
or the shoeshine guy or
the guy that cuts your hair
how their life is impacted.
And you know,
these news anchors,
most of them don't
really live normal lives.
- In Chris Cuomo's defense,
he did leave the house
when he had COVID
to get into the fight
with the bicyclist,
that his like $20 million
mansion in the Hampton.
So.
- Hey.
- It's not that he's not
getting out there, come on now.
- Yes.
It's. I mean it's good
work if you can get it.
- It is.
(laughing)
You mentioned you're a child
of the eighties and nineties,
one of the reasons I
like doing your show
is you get all of my references.
(laughing)
If I make a total
recall reference
or a Naked Gun
reference on your show,
you actually understand it,
I can talk about Cobra Kai
on your show and you get it.
- Yes.
- When I make
those references on Fox Daytime,
sometimes they don't get it.
They kind of nod, but I
know they don't get it.
Give me your best
eighties action movie.
I'm really flipping the
script on you right now.
- Well, I'm gonna go Top Gun
I mean, I know almost every
single word from that movie,
I saw it seven times in
the theater in the 1980s.
- Seven times at theater?
- Yeah,
I wanted to be a Top
Gun pilot afterwards
until I found out
(laughing)
that you have to be very
smart, you know, a lot smarter
than you have to be a
news anchor to be a pilot,
but it's a great movie,
and it was
(laughing)
one of those things,
and since we're on YouTube,
I'll tell this joke
and hopefully I won't get in
trouble for saying this, but.
- Oh.
- I remember
sitting in the movie
theater with my dad,
my best friend Gil and
his dad, we all four of us
and, a friend actually,
Gil had two brothers,
so we were there as well.
And I was with my dad
and there's that scene,
you know, when they're
in the bathroom
or in, then the bar, right
and you know, they're
talking about,
oh, the list is long and
distinguished, right Kazanski?
And he goes, yeah,
well, so is my Johnson.
And I leaned over to
my dad and I said,
dad, what's a Johnson?
And he just laughed.
You can make that sort
of comment on YouTube.
(laughing) Look how
free you are right now,
you've never been happier
than you are right
this very moment.
- You know, I say that though
because it was
like a simpler time
and I think nowadays,
and in context it was
just a movie, right,
but nowadays,
you're parent might get arrested
for bringing their
kid to a movie
and being exposed to
something like that.
There's just so much judgment
and you know, a lot of times
they make this stuff a lot
more provocative than it is
by trying to crack down on it.
- Yeah, well, the outrage thing,
I mean, it's like that's
gotta be a tough part for you.
I mean, one of the things,
you know I'm doing this
daily direct to camera
telling people what I think
about the world thing now.
And one of the things
that I really try to do,
I only do about
three stories a day
because I don't want
people to feel like
they're in that hamster
thing all the time.
When you sit down
with your producers
or your team in the morning.
- Hmm.
- To go through what
you're gonna talk about,
I sense you don't want
people in that either
but you have to give them more
stories as a true new show.
How do you,
like what are your
processes to make sure
you're not gonna make
everybody completely psychotic
but by the end of
(chuckles)
listening to you for an hour?
- Well, I mean, you have
the responsibilities,
we you have the the compulsory
stuff that you have to cover,
the information I think
that's critically important,
but I always try to
find something to
differentiate myself
and today I didn't even
actually get it on the air,
I'm gonna try to do it
at some point this week
but I'm fascinated by the
story about the death penalty,
you know because
growing up Catholic,
you're taught to respect life
from conception all the
way to natural death.
But over time as a libertarian
leaning, thinker kind of,
pursuer of information,
you read stories about
the death penalty,
how many times people are
released from death row
because DNA has
cleared their names,
and we have this new case now
or not a new case,
it's an old case,
but the execution.
- Yeah.
- Has been stayed this
week of this woman.
You know, this
would be the first
federal execution of a
female inmate in 7 years.
And so not a lot of
coverage on that,
in writ large,
and so that's something that
I'm focusing on this weekend.
I try to look at our
coverage across the network,
maybe on our website as well
and some other
conservative media
and say, what do I
think is interesting
and maybe not getting the
attention it deserves?
And that is just an example
of one story this week
that my producers like,
really, you wanna
talk about that?
Because it's not necessarily
right in the bullseye
of conservative news
topics to think about,
but the issue of
the death penalty
to approach from kind
of a thought experiment,
and does this really work from
a conservative standpoint,
it costs more money,
innocent people have
proven to be killed.
Yes, there is a
natural human instinct
to one catharsis after
something terrible happens,
but, you talk to
some of the people
who've actually had
lost family members
and have witnessed the
murder via executed,
and they don't feel any
catharsis after the fact,
they feel the
hollowness and emptiness
and they don't get the
closure they deserve.
And I'm not saying it's right
or wrong or should we have
the death penalty or not.
- Hmm-mm.
- But when it comes to thinking
about things critically
and this is right, do
we agree with this?
It hasn't happened
in seven years,
that right there
makes it newsworthy.
Those are the types of things
that get my brain going on,
should we put this
in the show today?
So that's just an (indistinct)
- Yeah.
- I'll look into that.
- Yeah. I mean, on that one,
you know as a guy that's kinda
new to the conservative thing
it's like, I take the
more libertarian approach
that you just laid out there.
I just don't wanna give
the state that extra power
and we do know that they
screw it up sometimes
but I get it, you know,
I've debated it with Shapiro
and with Prager and
some other conservatives
who are traditionally
more pro-death penalty,
but you know what,
we don't try to
kill each other after.
- All huge influences
of mine too, Dennis
Prager, Ben Shapiro,
Michael Knowles, you, everybody
there at the Daily Wire.
I mean,
and this like when you
were saying before,
a lot of times when
you are a conservative
or especially when you are,
as I was once a
conservative inside
you know a mainstream
media newsroom,
you really do need
inspiration sometimes too
because you think
you're going crazy
when everybody else
thinks the same way,
(laughing)
you're like, no, I
don't see it that way.
You know, you wanna
be the guy standing up
and saying wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait,
this isn't right.
You know, you and all
you guys over there
have been huge inspirations
over the years for me
entering this space, so
hats off to you guys.
- I was just gonna let you
continue for a little while,
while you were talking about
(laughing) what an inspiration
I've been to you really.
- That's always easier right?
It's always easy.
- When Trump over the
last couple of months,
especially right
before the election
was shining a lot
of light on you guys
and telling people,
watch Newsmax,
Fox in the morning is crazy,
watch Newsmax, they're
doing good stuff,
and then he'll
point people to OAN
and then the next day
he hates this network,
and suddenly he
likes these guys.
How sort of aware is
everybody that like,
oh, Trump's watching now
and we better, I don't know,
act accordingly, ignore it.
What?
- Everyone's very
aware obviously.
And, sometimes it's just
kinda strange knowing
that they have
us on at the White House
and that again,
something you say
might actually matter
inside that building.
And that again, there are times
I just can't believe
that's actually the case.
Now that said,
we do try to make sure that
we do not become Trump TV,
that's not the objective
here at Newsmax.
You know, the former
mayor of New York City,
Ed Koch had that saying that,
if you agree with me
80% of the time, great,
a 100% of the time,
you need to get your
head checked out
(laughing)
- [Dave] Yeah.
- And you know, no politician
is right a 100% of the time.
And as I tell people
and I try to encourage my staff
as much as you may
love Donald Trump
and I'm have to be reminded
of this and stuff myself,
because I really did think
the Trump presidency
could be transformational
and consequential,
and it has been,
and it's disappointing
that there will not
be another four years
because you think about all
the good things that happened,
what could have been continued.
But again, you just have
to really tell people that
once somebody, once you
bubble in that bubble
and choose somebody to
represent you in elected office,
they're not your friend anymore,
it's not your sports team,
you don't support
them like that,
you gotta hold them accountable
and we can compliment the things
that Donald Trump does right
and we can criticize the
things that he does wrong.
You know, it's the
only way you can really
honestly consider yourself
a check on the powerful
and if you don't
do it eventually
for somebody like Donald Trump,
or be honest with his supporters
you don't really have
the moral authority
or the credibility to
do it to Joe Biden.
And we've seen that
with other people,
you have to find someplace,
you can agree with
the opposition,
but also disagree
with your own side
- In a weird way, do you think
that that'll make your
job a little bit easier
having a Biden
administration because
people will know, okay,
you didn't want Biden
but now you can like, sort
of be more openly critical,
like I got you, you
weren't pulling punches,
but that in a weird way,
conservatives are almost set
up to be the against team,
you know?
- Well,
(chuckles)
I mean,
they're making it
kind of easy on us,
if they're really
gonna pursue this,
push to get rid of
the electoral college,
if they're really gonna
try to pack the courts,
if Joe Biden's
not gonna stand up
and stop the impeachment,
then yeah, I mean,
it does make our job easy.
If they pursue these
radical policies
that most of America outside of
major metropolitan
areas don't support,
it is gonna make our job easier.
If they continue to call
for defunding the police,
and we watch once great
cities like Los Angeles
and Philadelphia and New
York and Portland, Oregon
and Atlanta continue to decline
and become places of decay,
it's gonna make our jobs easier,
and I'm not hopeful for that,
I definitely wanna see
the best for America
but if they continue to
pursue these policies,
if they do what they tell
us they were going to do
during the campaign,
then I'm sad to say
that our jobs will
be much easier.
- Yeah,
God.
And as I said before,
I hate to tell you.
I think they're gonna do it.
- Yeah.
- I just,
my take is just that
they're gonna do it,
that they're, there's
just nothing too crazy
which is a very weird,
a very weird thing.
- And then again
this is where I come back
to the American people,
they're not gonna let
them do it I hope.
I was reading about this today.
- Well, what if
big tech just stops
the American people from
letting them connect?
I mean, that's the next.
- We can't let them.
- I go on your show and
talk about this a lot, yeah.
- Yeah, you know, the thing is,
is we existed without big tech
and I don't wanna diminish
the risk that this poses.
And you'll hear
about things like
email providers cracking down
on Donald Trump's ability
to reach his supporters
through email
and radio networks telling some,
you know, they are radio hosts,
and I, just yesterday
I was saying, look,
they're coming for
us on big tech, but
there may still be
those other avenues
where conservatives used
to reach their audiences.
And I am concerned about that,
but I do have faith in
the American public,
in Bartow County, Georgia today,
I was reading about a local
elections officials there
and the County
Commissioners there,
and they're doing a recount,
a hand recount of
all the ballots there
from the Georgia Senate runoffs.
Not that they need
to, it didn't qualify,
the race was not
within the margin
that they require the recount,
but what they're doing
is they're using this
as an opportunity
to build confidence
and show the people
who wanna participate
that it was a legitimate
process, complete transparency,
and they're also using
it to train people
how to be poll watchers
and how to process the
balance next time around.
So, I gave that a long
monologue last week
when you were on my show
about the real fight
is at the local level,
getting involved,
- Hmm-mm.
- People
rolling up their sleeves,
going to the school board,
going to the County commission,
becoming poll watchers,
becoming poll workers.
And, I'm so encouraged
to seeing that happening.
And again, you have
at 1.5 million people
that can be really mad if
something happens to your show.
And, we gotta pick our battles
to make sure they
can't do this to us.
We gotta hold our
lawmakers accountable
because they pass these laws
that they're not
willing to enforce.
You know, if they're
not going to do that,
get those laws off the books,
President Trump was right for
trying to repeal section 230.
You know, it's a
law from 1996, Dave,
and can you imagine
trying to use a
(chuckles)
computer from 1996
in today's technological world,
they need to get rid of
this law, it's expired.
- Are you saying my Apple IIc?
(laughing)
Or I guess that
was probably 1986,
not 1996.
- Did you have Cork,
the game Cork?
What was it?
- That was, Cork, oh no,
I'm thinking Kubert
is the guy jumping on the.
- Kubert.
- I know Kubert,
who's Cork?
- Cork was some game on
my Apple IIe I think,
and there was a Winter
Olympics too, I love that game.
Winter Olympics was in the game.
- I definitely remember
a Winter Olympics,
I had that on Nintendo, but
what about Lemonade Stand?
Did you have that?
- Lemonade Stand was a great,
and speaking of
the Winter Olympics
in the eighties since were,
how great were the
Winter Olympics
in the eighties when
you had the Eastern bloc
and you like, you know,
if the United States
(chuckles)
did not beat the Eastern bloc
and whether it was downhill
skiing or any sport,
it was like, oh, what does
this say about us as a nation?
- You know, I will
tell you this,
and I've said this on my
show a couple of times,
I think that like if
you think of Rocky four.
- Yes.
- You know, against Drago,
right, he's fighting Drago
in Moscow on Christmas day,
we knew as Americans
who our enemy was,
right.
- Yeah.
- It was Russia was the enemy,
now that's you don't wanna live
in a perfectly polarized world,
but I think that thing
where we were fighting
the Russian empire, we were
America for capitalism,
they were for communism,
it was like, that was the thing
and it sort of helped
define ourselves.
I actually think that
one of the reasons
we're so out of whack right now
is we don't know
who our enemy is.
- It's a great point.
- We don't know
if it's external or internal,
we don't know if the good
guys are the good guys
or the bad guys are bad guys,
did Russia effect our election
or hate Trump or
help Trump is China,
like none of it makes sense,
so people often
define themselves by
what they're against
and we don't know what
we're against right now.
- I know.
And you think about that movie,
you think about a Red Dawn
or you think about, there was
this movie called Russkies.
Remember that one about a,
you know, all the people
that used to defect,
and this is another
thing about sports is
people from Cuba or Russia
or Eastern European countries
that used to defect
to the United States
because we all believe this
was the best place for freedom
and now it feels like only
half of this country believes
that this is a place
you should actually
defect too if you're an athlete
but if you're, an immigrant,
they wanna open up the door
and let everybody in,
and it's just so
strange to hear that.
- It's a little odd that
nobody leaves America,
although I think that may be
changing kind of soon, right?
I mean, if it was as bad
for all of these
years as they'd said,
you'd think somebody
would leave.
The only people who
leave are the rich guys
who put the money in
the Cayman Islands
and disappear to the
Galapagos Islands.
- That's right.
They got someplace else to go.
And, you know, the, I
love this list of people,
I'm leaving if
Donald Trump wins,
(laughing)
of course, they never left.
You know, love it or
leave, it really is it.
And this is where I
wish more Americans
actually would travel
around the world
and appreciate how great it
is to live in this country
still to this day, how
much better we have it
than anywhere else.
I mean, we talk about big
tech cramping down on us
and I was just really repulsed
to see a Chinese communist
newspaper saying,
oh, look what's
happening in America,
it's dangerous to crack
down on free speech.
I mean, they're signaling to
their population that America,
the idea of America and
freedom and liberty,
you know,
life, liberty and the pursuit
of happiness, isn't real.
And the fact that that
doesn't get more coverage
or you don't have a universal
response from this country,
in fact, you have some news
outlets actually unwillingly,
not unwillingly, but unknowingly
taking money from the
Chinese Communist Party
and propagating their
propaganda without knowing it,
you know, you would
think to your point
that there would
be more awareness
about how dangerous the
enemy is, and that's China.
- Yeah.
Well, as a sports
guy, it's like,
you know, you watch the
NBA at which I didn't,
I literally for the
first time in my life
did not watch one minute of
one game this entire season,
I'm in LA,
the Lakers won the championship
from what I understand,
but I did not watch
one minute of it.
But the way that the
coaches and players
won't criticize China
under any circumstances
and who was it, it was
the like the assistant GM
of the Rockets or something
that basically
got destroyed for,
he was the one guy that said.
- Hmm-mm.
- Something anti-China.
And yet Steve Kerr
and Gregg Popovich
can rail all day long
about how evil America is
and they're like carrying
around on their shoulders.
- You know, I did an
interview with Enes Kanter,
the basketball player
for the Celtics,
I think he's on the Celtics now.
I do not follow the NBA at all
but you know, he's a Turkish
dissidence, dissonant.
- Yeah.
- We were talking about
Hagia Sophia
again they used to be a
secular tourists landmark
which was converted into an
Islamic mosque by Erdogan
as a, the virtue signaling
of the Arab world,
I'm sorry of the Muslim world,
that's what he's doing there.
And I asked him a question
about, look you, this,
you of all people should
appreciate how dangerous it is
to not be able to speak
out about this stuff.
Can you comment about what
the NBA and their inability
and I showed the
video of the people,
and this was again
offensive to me
that you had fans in
our nation's Capitol
who wore free Hong Kong
T-shirts inside the NBA arena
and they were not
allowed to do so,
they were escorted
out of the arena
and it shows you
how China has been able
to reach into America
and influence our lives.
I don't understand how more
people aren't offended by that.
- Yeah, that was one of those
moments that I was just like
how really perverse is this?
Like United States of America,
for people that haven't
seen it, they should,
you can pause this video
and just quickly
search it on YouTube,
Hong Kong shirts at NBA game.
- If you can find it Dave.
- I'm sure
the video will show up.
- I'm telling you, I have not.
- Yeah.
- We've done.
- Oh.
- We've tried to do
subsequent stories
and that stuff is
stripped off the internet.
It's hard to find it.
So, you know, that's again,
this is what we're up against.
- Jeez.
- China has control over YouTube
and I guess maybe this
will be cut, I don't know.
(laughing)
- This very, the us just
talking about that, right.
- I can say the dirty jokes.
- It's like, it's not.
- I can probably say the
dirty jokes from Top Gun
but I can't talk about
people wearing free Hong
Kong T-shirts in the NBA.
That's scary.
- Actually, I didn't
wanna tell you,
but I'll do a very
newsman thing,
I'm getting information
in my ear right now.
They will not allow us,
YouTube will not allow us
to play that Johnson joke
that you made earlier.
- Okay.
Probably for the best for.
- So.
- Probably for the best for my,
we can put a bleep or
something in there,
and you just tell people,
John Bachman said a dirty
joke one time quoting a movie,
not my dirty joke,
but probably for the
best Dave, thank you.
- It probably is for the best.
(laughing)
Yeah.
So everything sort
of feels upside down.
What else are you interested in
beyond just like
the political stuff?
- I love the ocean.
You know, I live in Florida,
I try to get to the beach
as much as possible.
I love to fish, I love to surf.
I love catching,
something I've done
recently with my small kids
is started fishing
with them a little bit.
And as a parent,
watching your young son
release a fish into the water,
something that I
did with my dad,
something that my dad
did with his grandfather
and his grandfather did with
his father and et cetera,
you know, this is
a family tradition,
that to me is the
ultimate right there.
So the outdoors, being with
my family and then food,
I think we shared that in
common, food is the other thing.
I basically live my
life from meal to meal,
I love to cook.
(laughing)
I'm greatly inspired by
your steaks that you cook,
I have so many questions
for you on that front.
Are you a reverse sear guy?
I mean, we can talk about
that some other time.
But yeah, those are the things
I'm interested in, my family.
- So you're a Florida guy,
wait, wait, let's
pause for a second,
we'll get to family in a sec,
but you're a Florida guy.
The day I got to Florida
a couple of weeks ago,
I think you were leaving,
you were headed to Georgia.
- Yes.
- I think.
Florida, it's free.
You're living in a free state,
I live in a not free state.
That's gotta be very
exciting for you
- You know, and I don't
take it for granted.
In fact talking to you
and talking to so many
people who are down here
for the turning point
USA Student Action Summit
from all over the country
and they had an
ability to get out
and do something normal
for just a few minutes.
And you really see,
and our conversation about this,
how important that
is to your life,
just there is a almost human
right to sit down at a table
and break bread with
someone you love or a friend
or business, colleague,
something like that,
have someone to
bring you the food,
pay a little bit
more money for it
and then they take it away
and you don't have
to clean it up.
I mean, that is.
- It's a beautiful thing.
- It is a beautiful thing
and I'll never take
it for granted.
You know, considering
that governor Ron DeSantis
made the very strong
and bold decision
to keep this state open.
And he is a hero to a lot
of people for doing that
because mentally Florida
seems to be the most
sane place in the
country right now,
if you could believe it.
- Would you have ever
thought that the state
that was known for Florida man
you know, people
wrestling alligators
with cigars in their mouths
while saving the dog,
very impressive guy by the way
who should probably
get into politics,
that Florida would go from that
to like having the governor that
pretty much every sane person
now wants to be the president?
- Well, I think a lot of people
underestimate Florida man,
it gets a bad rap, obviously
for all the criminality.
But I mean, there is something
(laughing)
called a Florida Cracker Dave.
- I always loved Florida
for the record. (laughing)
- Well, there's something
Called a Florida Cracker, right?
And it's not a derogatory
term, it's a term for a cowboy.
Florida actually has
one of the oldest
and largest
continually operating
cattle herds in the country
if you can believe it,
they use whips
but these are the old
Florida pioneer prospectors,
it is a real hardy type
and they are very useful.
And I think that is kind of
the underlying
spirit of Florida,
you have a lot of
diversity obviously,
and that breeds
competition of ideas,
you know, you've got
strong family values
because of all the Latino
influence down here as well.
And Florida has kind of
reached a maturation point
going from a retirement state
to now really a fully
functioning state
and I think that's what
you're seeing reflected here,
and don't mock Florida man.
There's a lot of great
Florida men out here that.
- No, no, listen,
(laughing)
you saw my tweets, I was like,
I hadn't been that
happy in a long time,
I mean, the state was
open, people were smiling,
everyone I see
here is in a mask,
not that I see anyone because
everything's closed anyway.
I walk my dog, people pull
their dogs across the other way.
The dogs are starting,
now I'm not kidding you,
the dogs are starting
to go crazy here.
- Well the dogs can,
I mean, you know.
- Because they can't be around
other dogs.
- Dogs can pick up
on human behavior
and they know, I mean, I think
that's an excellent point.
If your owner is freaking out
the dog's gonna be
freaking out too,
(laughing)
so I'm sure that's a real thing.
- I always say, you know,
there's no bad dogs,
there's just bad people,
right?
- True.
- It's like every time
someone, I'm walking the dog
and then someone pulls the
dog, oh, he's not friendly,
I'm like, well, it's
not really the dog,
(laughing)
you know.
- That's true.
- As you just yank the dog
and like freaking choked
it and everything else.
Do you sense that if we
get through inauguration
that the rest of the
States will start opening,
even Andrew Cuomo has
now started hinting
that he might open New York.
Basically, I mean, he's
not really admitting it,
but it's a basic
complete admission
that his policies
have been awful.
- Yeah, I mean, I think
Democrats like Andrew Cuomo
are learning the
limitations of their ability
to outsource the blame to
the federal government.
Because.
- Yeah.
- You know I've started to
take a closer look at this,
and operation Warp
Speed is a miracle,
the fact that, less than a year
after we have a
completely new virus,
you can have a vaccine,
but when you get down
to the local level
the rollout of the vaccines
has been disastrous,
and Andrew Cuomo is now
trying to cover for that.
He wanted to make it available
to frontline workers,
frontline workers
didn't want it.
And they,
and so they had
doses of the vaccine
going bad outside
of the freezer,
and now I think he's
just trying, flailing
to save himself.
And he can't blame Joe
Biden a week from now.
So, you know, he's
got to do something
and his state is dying
and I would hope for your sake,
and for everybody out
there in California
that Gavin Newsome sees
the writing on the wall
and follow suit.
- I think you were
the first guy,
was it you that
were the first guy
to ask me if I was going
to run for governor?
(chuckles)
- I think so.
- And I joked about
it on your show.
- I think so.
- And then I went to.
- You said, you must've.
- Then I went to.
- You must've tweeted something
that gave me that idea
because I'm pulling for
you to come over here, Dave
and hang out with us.
(laughing)
- I literally joked
about it on Twitter,
then you asked me
about it on your show,
next thing you
know I'm in Florida
and everybody everywhere,
and they asked me
about it on Fox
and yes, I think my future
would be much happier in Florida
than as the governor
of California.
I think that's
probably fair to say.
- Yeah, we need guys like
you not in politics, right.
Because if you're in politics
and you can't comment on
politics, we need, you know,
and everything, for some reason,
people always ask me if
I'm gonna run for office?
And I'm like, absolutely not.
I have, yeah, it's a
Shermanesque answer,
I would never, ever
run for office.
I like criticizing
office holders too much.
- Yeah, exactly.
Well, hey, listen, Trump ran
for office and criticized it,
so.
- Well,
I don't think we should
ever, I mean, Trump is like,
you know one of a kind
and for all he has done to
change the Republican Party,
for anyone who tries
to recreate that,
I think it's gonna be
just a fool's errand,
because he's a one of a
kind historical figure.
And it's gonna take a long time,
I think for any of us
to really understand
what we just experienced
over the last four years.
- John Bachman, I
feel I should give you
one more opportunity to
make an eighties reference.
Favorite comedy, somewhere
between 85 and 95.
How about that?
- Oof.
- There's a very
obvious answer to me.
- Ghostbusters, does that count?
- Well.
- Goonies?
- I suppose it.
- Is that in that time range?
- Ghostbusters is,
Goonies, not in terms of funny.
- You don't think
Goonies is funny?
- Funny.
No, Goonies is funny,
there's some funny moments,
but that's not pure funny,
Ghostbusters.
- Spaceballs?
- Ghostbusters is funnier,
Spaceballs could
be in there too.
I mean to me, I think
I mentioned it earlier,
Naked Gun to me is.
- Okay.
- It's perfection, it's
Leslie Nielsen perfection.
Like it's airplane at
its peak basically.
But interesting, Goonies.
- Yes.
- Goonies is more
hard screams.
- You know I remember Goonies,
I just recently watched Goonies
with my kids over
the holiday break,
and I remember
going to see Goonies
with my grandmother
in the movie theater,
and she did not like Goonies.
And after watching
it with my kids,
I realized maybe
this shouldn't be PG.
PG, you know, different.
- There is some
sex jokes in there.
- If you look at the ratings
too from the movies
back in the eighties
and what's PG now, I don't
know if that would fly,
but anyway, I think it
was cooler back then,
you had a better relationship
with your parents,
they could explain things to you
and you didn't have stuff,
I really worry
about the kids today
because they're just bombarded
with stuff on the internet.
It's hard for them to avoid
the things we were
able to avoid as kids,
it's hard for them to
maintain their innocence.
Bachman, I hope you
enjoyed loosening the tie.
- Go all the way down, yeah.
- It's,
and speaking freely
on the interweb,
I will see you soon
I assume on your show
and then eventually I will grill
a steak for you in Florida.
- Ooh,
I will sear
the hell of a steak for you
in Florida.
- What's your cut by the way?
What's your preferred
cut of steak Dave?
- I've been loving
these tomahawks lately,
you know, just like the Fred
Flinstone style Tomahawk,
I did like a four pound
one the other day,
now I know that in California
technically you're not allowed
to have people at your house
and I don't wanna say too much
but let's just say it
was, people ate it,
I don't wanna get
into the numbers in
case Gavin's watching,
but man, it was just perfection.
Yeah.
- We'll just say it like this,
none of it was wasted.
Right, and they can
appreciate that hopefully.
- None of it was wasted.
- Dave, I appreciate
it, thanks so much.
- John Bachman, the host of
John Bachman Now on Newsmax.
(intense ambient music)
If you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about the media
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our media playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
check out the full
episode playlist,
they're both right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.